so this is this is actually very serious
because
this could be uh this could be the start
of a ramp up of violence by trump
supporters
as we approach inauguration day for
president-elect joe biden
um as i mentioned earlier there was
another one of these million maga
marches in dc this weekend
this time the trump supporters the proud
boys the white supremacists they were
actually starting to get violent
setting fires to black lives matter
banners including at churches
getting into stabbing fights multiple
arrests we'll talk about it more on the
bonus show but what i really want to
focus on today is not that part because
we'll get to that a little bit later
but rather how this is all part of a
building republican civil war
between factions of the right you've got
the crazy right
and the really crazy right that are kind
of battling
and one of the chants that was heard
this weekend in washington dc at this
march
was destroy the gop destroy the
republican party
and the reasons that different trumpists
are mad at republicans
are numerous and wide-ranging it's
actually funny different
elements of the trump cult are mad at
the republican party or republicans
but for different reasons that sometimes
conflict it's a comedy of errors but one
that could have real
repercussions over the next few years
and election cycles
some trumpists are mad at the republican
party because some republican officials
like brian kemp in georgia
haven't been willing to overtly try to
steal the election for donald trump and
they're furious
at brian kemp they're furious at brad
raffensberger the secretary of state in
georgia
and so on others are mad at the
republican party
because they're mad that the right-wing
supreme court justices
refused to hear a completely bogus
lawsuit
about non-existent voter fraud so some
of the ire is there
and why don't you republicans do more to
hold these people accountable apparently
not understanding
how the supreme court works other trump
cultists
are mad at fox news because they because
fox news acknowledges that joe biden won
at least during like the daytime
programming on their network
so this is interesting stuff here is a
guy
introducing another guy named nick
fuentes who's from one of these like
extra radical pro-trump wings of the
right saying
right-wingers like charlie kirk and ben
shapiro
uh essentially aren't radical enough and
in fact
you know now i'm questioning i don't
know if nick fuentes is still part of a
pro-trump right or if
they've separated it's a complete and
total mess but listen to what was said
here ben
shapiro does not believe in america
first
he started the never trump movement ben
shapiro
is a subversive
so now ben shapiro is too far left i
guess partially because ben shapiro was
anti-trump
um it's initially even though ben
shapiro voted for trump and then out
comes nick fuentes himself
and he gets to destroy the republican
party chant going
and the first million manga marks we
promised
that if the gop would not do everything
in their power to keep trump in office
then we would destroy the
and as we gop here in washington dc for
a second
million month of march we're done making
promises
it has to happen now we are going to
destroy the gop
so of course in thinking about the
future of the republican party
there's like an actual academic
discourse to be had about the future of
the two-party system
and the future of the republican party
within that and changing
demographics and how that might
influence things and gerrymandering and
redistricting
but then there's sort of like this other
uh question mark
which is if trump remains really visible
after leaving office that will have a
very different effect on these
subgroups in the republican party than
if trump disappears
from view and we won't know that for for
a few weeks
there could be a big reconciliation
among the right and all of these
elements come back together uh
it's you know this is not an
irreversible grudge that we are seeing
if trump leaves all of these groups may
quickly realize hey
what we really hate is the left and
they'll be back together in no time
on the other hand if donald trump
remains visible once he's out of office
and continues weaponizing the cultists
against other aspects of the republican
party
this could continue for some time
remember what lindsey graham
said i guess it was four or five years
ago now if we nominate trump we will get
destroyed and we will deserve it
maybe looney lindsay really was on to
something there and it would be great if
this did end up throwing the republican
party
into such chaos that they implode for a
few election cycles i do think we should
encourage it i mean
why not foment the feeling when you're
talking to traditional republicans
that these trumpists are making them
look insane and then when you're talking
to the trumpists foment the idea that
these traditional republicans clearly
aren't committed to their movement and
they've betrayed them on this election
issue i think it's an absolutely great
idea
but to really know what the future of
this is going to be
we have to see what happens after the
biden inauguration how
visible does trump remain and sort of go
from there i don't think we'll really
know
whether the republican party is gearing
up for a sustained civil war
until it's more clear what role if any
trump will have within the republican
party
uh after january 20th so we will wait
for that
and after the break i will tell you all
about what is taking place today
to make that uh inauguration of joe
biden
um an inevitable reality via the
official vote of the electoral college
a lot of the shirts you see me wearing
on youtube are actually made by a
company called
teddy stratford i love these shirts and
that's why i asked them to be a sponsor
of the show
it really is the most innovative shirt
you can buy
because most slim fit button-up shirts
give you this weird stretched out gap
in the chest where the buttons are you
don't get that with the teddy stratford
shirts because
all of their shirts come with a patented
zipper
hidden beneath the buttons which
prevents the chest from stretching apart
like that but
most importantly just overall it makes
the shirt
fit much better and look better the
carefully designed shirt is also
cut in a way that improves the look of
your upper body physique it has a really
nice elegant
close fit that other shirts don't really
give you it also has a specially
designed
collar that won't fall down and lay flat
which i love
the difference all around with these
shirts really is noticeable
go check them out at davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15
off your first order if you use the
coupon code pacman at checkout